good morning
I'm dr. Alan Jaffe I'm a professor of
medicine and a professor of laboratory
medicine and pathology at the Mayo
Clinic in Rochester Minnesota and today
we're going to talk about the use of
more sensitive cardiac troponin assays
to evaluate patients who have potential
cardio toxicity I think it's an
important topic and it's one that's
going to become more and more common
because cardio toxicity in particularly
as it relates the cancer therapy is
going to become much more common and I
show you this first set of pictures just
to sensitize you to some of the panoply
of effects that you might in the long
run see these include arrhythmias
including QT prolongation which can give
you malignant ventricular arrhythmias
that are life-threatening heart failure
shown in the middle thromboembolism as
we begin to use more vgf inhibitors we
begin to interdigitate with the
thrombotic system hypertension we know
toxicity with its secondary effects all
of which can lead to acute angina and or
myocardial infarction to give you some
more substantive examples if indeed you
begin to develop heart failure the
frequency of super ventricular
arrhythmias will become much more common
atrial fibrillation for example is
almost always a manifestation of heart
failure or one sort
similarly there are a variety of agents
shown at the bottom that can cause QT
prolongation which can cause these
malignant arrhythmias called Prasad the
quant which are a life-threatening
malignant ventricular arrhythmias and
there are a variety of drug interactions
that facilitate these types of
arrhythmias in addition
some of the anti metabolic patients the
most common 5-fu can cause coronary
Veysel conscription and that's the
reason why the Japanese in particularly
have presented multiple cases of ST
segment elevation transient albeit that
is associated with cardiac toxicity and
probably is a direct effect I'm a
coronary vasculature causing Facebook
constriction finally as we begin to
interdigitate and cause thrombotic
processes as you can see all of the
anti-vegf analogs are prone to cause
thrombotic complications which has most
of you know are the proximate cause of
acute myocardial infarction in most
instances the heart failure area is one
that really has gotten the most
attention and it therefore serves as a
paradigm to begin to discuss how we're
going to evaluate patients but I would
call your attention to the fact that
this is the tip of the iceberg and that
with time this interdigitating between
cardiology and chemotherapy is going to
become greater because of what I just
showed you if one begins to look
although this slide says that heart
failure is two to ten percent depending
upon the agent I'm gonna make the
argument that if one really begins to
follow patients long term based on the
work of Lipchitz and colleagues as I'll
show you in a couple of minutes that the
frequency of cardio toxicity is going to
become even greater and this has been
stimulated really by the ability to
follow children receive chemotherapy and
in point of fact is as indicated by the
title of this article in the sentence
I've called out from it this is an
increasing group of patients in regard
to some of the specific data and I've
underlined some of it here for you to
see more than half of all patients young
patients who received anthracyclines
which is about 60,000 have some cardiac
abnormality and 5% or so have been
collected developed congestive heart
failure now I would argue that in
particularly as you add comorbidities
with life that that's probably a
conservative number and so and and it
may well be that this is even greater as
time goes on as suggested by these
authors one looks the same thing if one
looks at cardiovascular comorbidities in
this study an Eightfold increase in
survivor of childhood cancer now some of
this may have to do with techniques that
were now sensitive to involving
radiation therapy and the like but again
there going to be other more aggressive
forms of chemotherapy to take the place
of those cardiotoxic insults this is
simply again another example looking at
testicular cancer again showing the
increased risk of cardiovascular events
it's accompanied by the mere treatment
to say nothing of the fact that many of
these people may have cardiovascular
comorbidities now this whole field was
really stimulated by an FDA investigator
named Herman who in this manuscript
began to look at patients with troponin
and asked the question whether or not
patients who receiving anthracyclines
had elevations and here's his original
data he sampled at one for a 24 and 48
hours just in 10 patients utilizing a
very early relatively insensitive assay
and at the end we'll talk about the
inter digitation of very high sensitive
assays which will be give us a lot
better information but will also cause
some real issue
in regard to how we interpret those and
how we use them going forward but what
Herrmann described the first time was
the fact that there was a signal of
cardiac damage which is what an elevated
troponin means in patients who are
receiving anthracyclines he went further
and he used anthracyclines animal
experimental animals and showed there
was disruption of the cytoplasmic
vacuoles and myofibrillar disruption as
shown in this slide and went on to
document the fact that these elevations
in troponin is supposed to be related to
some nonspecific phenomena because at
the time we really were not as a student
to all of the meanings of elevated
components really did reflect damage to
Maya sites and he showed over time in a
series of studies not published in the
most prestigious of the journals that
treated patients compared to controls
tended to have higher levels of cardiac
troponin over time now this whole area
was right for investigation and a young
investigator in Milan Daniela Cardinale
really deserves the credit for finding
this phenomenon and really beginning to
look at it clinically with the idea of
road how to document it and how to treat
it and her work is really seminoles
we'll go through a little bit of it at
present she looked at a group of men and
women who receiving potentially Kamath
their chemo toxic their excuse me cardia
toxic chemotherapy they were not this
was not a pure group at the time there
were
a variety of different protocols used
and different diseases but what she was
able to show again utilizing a
relatively insensitive assay was that
those individuals who had elevated
components were about a third of the
population importantly one looked at
that population those were the
individuals not surprisingly if you have
damage to your myocardium the likelihood
of developing a reduced ejection
fraction which is a surrogate for
cardiac performance is substantial and
know early on we're not talking about
drops that normally people who are
giving chemotherapy are sensitive to we
often wait until there are very very
mark drops but these are substantial
drops of 10 and 12 and 15 ejection
fraction points and what they do is as
I'll show you in a couple of minutes is
presage the development of an increasing
degree of LV abnormality these
reductions in ejection fractions were
also followed by changes in left
ventricular volume this is not
unexpected what happens is that we
damage the heart and reduce ejection
pressure the heart increases its volume
to maintain stroke volume and one ends
up with an increased volume now in truth
if one begins to look at the
cardiovascular literature ejection
fraction is not nearly as good as
surrogate for long term comorbidity has
our LD volumes which are much more
sensitive and much more associated with
adverse effects over time and as you can
see here even if you're not impressed by
the degree to which the ejection
fraction fell the volumes are markedly
increased and there are increase to the
level when we do studies looking at
patients
was my according fortune proposed other
insults that effect on my accordion are
associated with quite an adverse
prognosis and there was a relationship
albeit rough between the magnitude
utilizing a Spearman correlation of the
troponin elevations and the ejection and
Daniele then went beyond that
to look at another group and again ask
the question whether or not there was a
consistent pattern and as you might
expect there were some individuals who
had transient elevations some who had
none and some who had a large number of
persistent elevations and again not
surprisingly if one counts mase which is
then the components of that are listed
on the left sudden that cardiac death
pulmonary edema heart failure a
reduction in left ventricular ejection
fraction by 25% life-threatening
arrhythmias in conduction disturbance as
you can see there was a very high
incidence in the individuals who had
elevated components in ER immediate
incident and those who had transient
elevations that were no longer detected
and very very good response in those who
had normal and she suggested the
following risk stratification algorithm
based on monitoring proponents over time
now because there were indications in
experimental models that cardio toxicity
associated anthracyclines might be
related to oxidative stress and given we
knew at the time that ACE inhibitors
were inhibitors of oxidative stress
after some initial studies that were
done in hamster models suggesting that
ACE inhibitor is inhibited
the cardiotoxicity doctor Cardinale
tried this patients what she did was to
look at patients who had early
cardiotoxicity if indeed of the hundred
and fourteen patients you had an
elevated component which is about a
quarter of that then you were randomized
to either receive an ala perl for
control and you were then followed this
was started a month after high-dose
chemotherapy the endpoint is shown here
which is the number of patients whose
ejection fraction decreased by more than
ten percentage points were less than
fifty in the ACE inhibitor group this
was totally related in controls it was
43 percent and if you look at the data
related to troponin there were
elevations and proponent in the control
subjects that persisted his chemotherapy
was continued to be administered whereas
in the individuals who received the ACE
inhibitors there was reduction in the
amount of troponin that was released and
if one looked with that preservation of
cardiac function terms of secondary
endpoints terms of other issues that
were related they were relatively sparse
but heart failure not surprisingly and
some arrhythmias were quite common now
at this point in time one could make an
argument that perhaps everybody
receiving anthracycline should be put on
an ACE inhibitor to inhibit oxidative
stress what I gather from my colleagues
in oncology that oxidative stress may be
part of the mechanism for chemotherapy
so it is not we're not yet at the point
based on the science as I understand it
for us to simply advocate that everybody
go on an ace inhibitor not only that ace
inhibitors have their own toxicity
absolutely no toxicity that can be
associated this a usual but obviously
small percentage of individuals who have
allergic reactions rashes and the like
so we're not ready to simply say treat
everybody with ace inhibitors if one
looks at Krista Samantha as well
doctor cardinality next turned her
attention to this and you look you can
see that trastuzumab also caused
reduction in ejection fraction that some
patients had that resolved with these
discontinuation or overtime after
therapy and you can see there was a
variety of times when this occurred but
it was often early during treatment and
part of the confounds of this that need
to be investigated still further is the
fact that as the oncologists know very
very well the vast majority of patients
in these trials really had received
anthracyclines first and then Christina
what I think is important however if one
looks at the characteristics of patients
who didn't recover and I wouldn't focus
on this slide because it simply says
that the patients who didn't recover
were worse off but the most important
part about it was that those individuals
usually were the ones who had elevated
components and that there was some
transient dysfunction when it was not
associated with elevated component it
was not associated usually with the
persistence of quite a vascular toxicity
including the tabulation which they
showed he
we simply tabulate the number of
toxicities and the number of events that
occurred in each of the groups those
with and without well notice studies
were done with contemporary assays some
of which are still in use today but they
are relatively sensitive compared to the
assays that are coming and they're
coming soon as a matter of fact high
sensitivity assays are available now in
almost all parts of the world the
exception of the United States
where the FDA has not yet approved them
and in fairness to the FDA they've not
yet been submitted to the FDA but they
should be soon and they give you one eye
some idea of what high sensitivity will
mean shown on this next slide if you
look at the number of normal subjects
that are detected by any given assay you
can see the conventional assays are
shown here in the middle in this study
by Fred Apple which I've reconfigured to
make it I think clearer in the brownish
sort of area you can see that most
passes don't detect very many if any
normal subjects to give us a number
point-of-care assays are similar and in
point of fact many would suggest that
the point-of-care assays are exaggerated
by this analysis at the bottom the so
called high sensitivity assays you can
see depending upon which one you pick
detects somewhere from eighty to a
hundred percent of normal subjects that
doesn't mean those people are abnormal
what it really means is that there's
simply a number attached that's one way
of looking at sensitivity please note
that originally we thought that the
roach high sensitivity troponin T is a
detected
50% or more such patients but subsequent
analysis and these results were
generated by the companies so this was
not a function of who did the
evaluations
these were samples sent to companies
suggest that perhaps it doesn't meet
this metric and dr. Apple has suggested
that the metric for high sensitivity
ought to be a 50% detection rate so that
what is called the high sensitivity
troponin TSA and that's well astonished
and literature and you'll so you'll see
it may indeed be a bit of an
exaggeration
please note there's an occasional
conventional assay that does pretty well
but also know that for most these high
sensitivity assays are really a major
leap in sensitivity and they've already
been used by single X which has probably
the most sensitive of these assays to
look at quite a toxicity and in point of
fact the pharmaceutical industry I think
quite wisely has begun to use these to
begin to screen experimental agents in
animal models for cardiotoxicity one
needs to be careful in doing that
because not there is not homology in
every animal species and there are data
now generated by Fred Apple for a group
called se which is a group of the safety
consortium that works for the
pharmaceutical industry defining which
assays tend to work for which animal
species because they do have different
levels of homology the epitopes for the
assays are different but using the high
sensitivity assay here's one example of
what happens with hydralazine and given
to rats at a dose of 25 milligrams per
kilogram here is another one and this
really is sort of the poster trial
because of the controversy over the use
of glitter zone type drugs this looks at
the increases in rosiglitazone at higher
doses so this is happening it's
happening in pharmaceutical industry in
fairly great proliferation and they're
starting to utilize this strategy the
screen drugs because they'd rather no
accordian cardiotoxicity is possible
before the drug begins to be given the
patients then after now there are very
few data using high sensitivity troponin
in inpatients here's one example that is
in the literature and it suggests
something that perhaps we should not be
surprised about and that is that a
substantial number of patients 19% had
substantial elevation because in truth
although you don't know the numbers for
this I can tell you that the 99th
percentile or the cutoff values for
women are about 16 with this particular
assay and it's about 34 to 36 for men so
45 is substantial elevation and of these
in response to anthracycline 54% let an
elevated troponin developed quite a
toxicity current followed but there
going to be some real challenges in
using this and I think it's important
before we start to emerge and start to
say how are we going to do this that we
understand those challenges one
challenge is that are going to be
baseline elevations and in truths it may
turn out that those baseline elevations
are terribly important impressive
perhaps patients who have elevated
baseline values even if they're
clinically not detected
have an underlying cardiac comorbidities
that may make them much more prone
cardiotoxicity and that's a very very
important issue that is presently being
probed in several ongoing studies just
one example one looks at what happens
with age and high sensitivity or quote
high sensitivity troponin values this
utilizing what I told you was the maybe
high sensitivity troponin TF you can see
that with age their tremendous numbers
of individuals that increase their
values the normal values here are 10 for
men and 50 10 for women and 15 for men
to substantially high levels and they
represent for the most part as best we
can tell underlying comorbidities that
is to say all of us as we get a little
bit older we could argue that cut point
is are going to have some elevations in
our troponin
now in truth we can't simply say alright
we're going to change the cutoff values
that we need to expect in patients based
on age because in point of fact there
are substantial numbers of males and
females of older age who kept themselves
in great shape and don't have elevations
so we're going to end up having to use a
changing that you set of values but
looking to see whether or not there is a
comorbidity to start with is going to be
terribly important this is simply
another example of this and this example
simply takes a variety of subtle quite a
vascular comorbidities such as mild
hypertension mild changes in renal
function left ventricular hypertrophy
diastolic dysfunction and suggests that
the curves that we see utilizing in this
since high sensitivity Siemens si is
going to cause a mild shift in in the
numbers for high sensitivity troponin so
we're gonna have to be sensitive to the
starting point and get baseline samples
number two with high sensitivity samples
and eye sensitivity assays we're going
to have to be much better at making sure
our samples are are obtained in a good
way I can tell you putting on my lab hat
at about 75% of the abnormal values that
we see in the laboratory aren't related
to the analytics of the testing but are
related to the sample handling here's
one example we get most of our samples
in a intensive care units from wines and
a large percentage of them from the Edie
from wines if you do that and you get
hemolysis you can see in this example
you lower cardiac troponin t levels will
increase proponent high levels this is
an important distinction and therefore
if you're going to obtain sample what
we're going to need to do is to make
sure the samples are good quality there
may be elevations that are due to
chemotherapy but there also is the
possibility that individuals who get
receiving chemotherapy could have cardio
toxicity of overriding sorts that could
have underlying coronary artery disease
they're certainly prone to develop
cardiomyopathies and all of the things
that could happen to anybody else so
there's going to be a difficulty in
distinguishing that and sometimes these
can be subtle this is an example of a
study that was done by Jim Janu Z at the
Massachusetts General Hospital and the
purpose of the study was to try and look
for coronary artery disease and they
then
were imposed high sensitivity troponin
values and what they found that
surprisingly was even if they didn't
find that the patient had an acute
coronary syndrome that there were
elevations of cardiac troponin high
sensitive in all of those individuals
who had any sign or semblance of
underlying coronary artery disease or
comorbidities such as diabetes a history
of lig disease regional war motion
abnormalities but even more importantly
even if they had structural heart
disease that is to say if they had left
atrial enlargement left ventricular
enlargement left ventricular hypertrophy
and a panoply of leads so that this is a
terribly important to understand that
these can be subtle comorbidities and
that we are going to need to learn how
best and cost-effectively to interrogate
patients when we see elevations in high
sensitivity proponents and not simply
assume that chemotherapy is the only
thing that could cause such elevations
in point of fact if one looks at
patients and this looks at a cohort of
patients who were thought to have stable
coronary disease the higher the troponin
meaning the more ongoing cardiac damage
there is the worst patients do and the
consequence of that is that as soon as
you see these elevations whether it is
due to something that is intrinsic to
patient the chemotherapy were both
because cardio my Pathak's stimuli are
additive one to the other it should call
for the need for intervention to
evaluate why because the prognosis in
these individuals is adverse and this is
one example that cohort of stable
disease patients here is yet another
utilizing the ice high sensitivity assay
and showing that when you take patients
with risk factors or under
coronary disease they splay out like
this and what's going to start to happen
is that those of us who follow
cardiovascular patients are going to
start to adhere to this as well so
you're going to be superimposing
whatever chemotherapy exists on whatever
is the underlying quite a vascular
substrate of your patient it's going to
turn out that these high sensitivity
assays are going to be very helpful
here's just one example of looking at
patients who start out with heart
failure you can see just like deciles of
cardiac troponin high sensitivity that
you can predict both mortality and
rehospitalizations we could go on and on
but I won't but there's going to be a
tremendous amount of information coming
out to lead to both diagnostic and
prognostic information as well as
therapeutic interventions now one of the
things and you've heard me talk about
this already that is very likely to be
terribly important the use of gender
specific cut-offs this is simply a
tabulation of the number of assays that
have been used with high sensitivity
looking at gender specific cut-offs and
the reality is that women have
substantially lower values than men the
diagnostic industry is not terribly
happy about this they would love there
to be something simple one cut off one
magic number for individuals to remember
but it appears very likely that they're
going to be to one per men and one for
women we haven't in the situation of
acute ischemic heart disease I would
argue under treat women often in large
part because they're proponents are
frequently not elevated because their
coronary artery disease is different so
that it is very likely in the chronic
circumstance that the knee
we'll be four oncologists as well as
cardiologists to keep in mind the need
for gender specific cut-offs in
evaluating this so we don't under
diagnosed women and concurrently over
time those men then there's going to be
an issue of how we should treat these
individuals it's not at all clear
and there are sophisticated regimens
that are now ongoing looking at ways of
inhibiting cardio toxicity that may be
far better than ACE inhibitors and we
need to do the trials to make sure that
whatever therapies we use do not inhibit
the results of chemotherapy which thus
far have been excellent and how do we
monitor this well we probably can
monitor the progression of quite a
toxicity with high sensitivity
components but it's not going to be as
easy as we thought because of the
concomitant comorbidities that could
occur patients who are who have those
comorbidities have an underlying
propensity to ret have their components
go up so if they have mild art fair and
it gets worse they will have a higher
elevation of their of their high
sensitivity troponin so this is going to
take consistent serial measurements and
one of the issues that has occurred in
the field from my perspective and many
people have challenged the ideas of
Cardinal and I think the reason for that
is that we there's a tendency to get
spotty sampling infrequently you've
admix assays and you can't follow cereal
samples if you had mixed assays and not
interdigitate the information from the
troponin with what's going on in
clinical history of the patient we still
don't know although it's likely if we
inhibit damage to Maya sites that we
will reduce the long-term effects of
cardio toxicity so that
as opposed to overtime one having these
market increase that liberals and
colleagues have so elegantly documented
that will reduce long term
cardiotoxicity
but the number of long term studies with
the exception of those and children are
very very few and far between are
desperately needed because it is still
conceivable that although we've watched
the cardiotoxicity that some still
exists that will be synergistic with
other cardiotoxic circumstances whether
it is intrinsic to the patient as part
of their disease or to their or to the
disease itself or to the chemotherapy it
also may be as we find more about other
agents that some of the other agents we
use may adore digitate so knowing this
will be important and there likely will
be some surprises this is an area where
I think in the absence of some degree of
rigor and standardization but I would
hope the field will come to that the
values will turn out to be very
difficult to interpret and I receive
phone calls periodically for my
colleagues to try and deal with these
patients and say well it's in so-and-so
center and I don't know what assay they
use they don't know what I say they use
so that there is the need for real
molding of protocols and algorithms to
look at this it is my advocacy that if
we do that we'll end up with good
results if we don't we'll have many many
more surprises with that I will close my
formal remarks and simply say that this
is happening now we're starting to
measure these things there's groups
starting to perform chemotherapy
clinics that have cardiovascular
consultation associated with them this I
think is a good thing and will help
patients in the long run but high
sensitivity will be here in the United
States probably within a year
maybe it will take a little longer it's
available in the rest of the world and
unless we start to learn about it it's
going to come as a confusion rather than
what it ought to be which is a way an
opportunity to really improve the care
of patients who are receiving
potentially cardiotoxic chemotherapy
with that I'll take questions they're in
my question box and I'll try and answer
them in the order they have been
received and I'll read the question
first it says either studies using C key
CPK ISO enzymes instead of proponent of
conventional troponin there were
attempts to look at chemotherapy
toxicity with CK and ck-mb and those
assays were insufficiently sensitive to
detect cardio toxicity this was only
unmasked with the greater sensitivity of
the troponin I have no more questions in
the queue but I'd be delighted if if
people would send some in if you have
questions because I think this is going
to be common area where hopefully those
of you who are listening are going to
need to become much more expert so I'll
hold for just a couple of minutes and
wait
well yeah I think if if there are no
more questions just go to the last slide
and this is the way in which for those
of you who listen to this thought can
receive CME credits here is your link
and I thank you very much for listening
there's one more question that has just
come in I'll take it one of the units
that's it's a good question thank you
and I'm glad it was asked when we
standard proponents have been reported
as nanograms per milliliter if one goes
to high sensitivity proponents you end
up with so many zeros that many of us
were concerned that those zeros were
going to eventually cost somebody their
life by having somebody misses zero we
were convinced of that when one of the
recent articles on high sensitivity
troponin in JAMA came out with all of
the zeros in the wrong place so those of
us involved in actually internationally
has taken the tack and I think this will
happen that we should be using whole
numbers
so for example when I use the number 10
that's 10 nanograms per liter so that
the change is at the end set of
milliliters its leaders and that allows
us to use core numbers that's a terribly
important issue that people will have to
get used to for those of you who are
used to conventional component assays
where there are lots of zeros as we get
more sensitive
thank you very much and with that I'll
leave you I appreciate your attention